in our series world of worship we're
exploring different ways people practice
faith and religion around the globe
today we're taking a look at one of the
fastest growing religions in the world
the Baha'i faith there are now more than
100,000 Baha'i communities worldwide CBS
this morning Saturday co-host there she
is Dana Jacobson hey Dana recently
visited one in Wilmette Illinois so the
question is Dana what's the heart of
this religion well Gail the one word
that we kept hearing to describe the
Baha'i faith was unity in Arabic it
means follower of glory it was founded
in 1844 in Iran and the religion teaches
the oneness of all world religions with
principles that seem universal if you're
intrigued come on with me now on a
journey to the mother temple of the West
just outside Chicago on the shores of
Lake Michigan construction started in
1921 sits the oldest surviving Baha'i
house of worship every Baha'i temple has
nine sides nine doors nine gardens and
fountains what significance of nine nine
is a symbol of completeness and unity
joy slit off was attracted to the Baha'i
faith because she says it teaches what
she already believes my mother was
Jewish my father was Catholic and then I
married a Jewish man so I've actually
lived in two religious communities yeah
and when I learned about the Baha'i
faith that embraces the teachings of
other religions it made total sense to
me the idea of oneness is carved into
the temples exterior which includes the
Jewish Star of David the Christian cross
and the star and crescent of Islam and
it's the idea that this is encompassing
all religions all faiths well that's a
little bit of a misconception that the
Baha'i faith is a mishmash that we we
believe everything we believe in this
progressive revelation that the
teachings of these great spiritual
teachers they all had their time and
place and so we embrace the religions
that came before Baha'is believe theirs
is the religion of the future
inside each temple there's one dome
representing one God be generous in your
days of
at least twice a day there are prayer
services with readings from various
world religions but no sermons and no
clergy that lack of ritual is partly
what drew 28 year-old Matthew cotton to
the faith we lived in mostly all-black
neighborhood he was raised Catholic on
the south side of Chicago what did your
mom think well you know coming here she
was very supportive you know at first
she wanted to ask some clarifying
questions that if this was a cult and so
you know I told her to the best of my
knowledge it didn't seem like a cult to
me right this really seemed like a
global world religion of people engaging
with their fellow citizens who weren't
behind in order to be of service to
humanity what is the United community
that the Baha'i faith is trying to
achieve to me building unity looks like
creating opportunities for everyone to
see themselves as part of one family so
no matter race exactly no matter
economic status yes exactly I mean
gender anything yes seeing each other
first
as souls we may come in different colors
we're human kind music director van
Gilmer has been working toward racial
justice since the civil rights era in
1963 he participated in sit-ins in
Greensboro North Carolina
the idea of one humanity is very
attracting we talked about it in my
church but my church is african-american
that church in Greensboro not coming
it's still african-american all the
churches in Greensboro occupy either one
race or another race we say and we
believe one thing but if when it comes
to what we're doing about it
if we're not showing it if we're not
working at it practicing then those were
the things that influenced me to become
a Baha'i because there's no hierarchy in
the religion the highs around the world
elect at least nine people to represent
them and their local spiritual assembly
there are no ministers so the burden is
back on the individual to not only read
the right
things that the best thing in my sight
is justice right to be to be just not to
just read or have somebody talk about it
to me but try to figure out how I'm
going to be just and the things that I
do a community working toward justice by
focusing on practicing instead of
preaching now there are somewhere
between five and six million behind wide
and about a hundred seventy seven
thousand here in the United States there
are eight continental four high temples
making it the second most geographically
diverse religion in the world and that's
behind Christianity temples are really
stunning you architects apparently I
knew nothing about it that was very
interesting I like what he said one
humanity is very attractive and he was
talking about in the 60s he told us all
these stories about obviously he's a
black man in North Carolina at the time
and white and black together at a time
where that didn't happen he would see a
white family show up and would think why
are they here and what is going on so
this has been their message from the
beginning that idea of unity very much